Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new marvel infinity saga
re-watch video for Iron Man 2
we're rewatching all the MCU movies
pointing out all the big Marvel phase 4
Easter eggs and details that we missed
the first time we watched them if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing that
special infinity saga box set giveaways
as part of this all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and rank the
Iron Man movies from your most favorite
to least favorite so careful for
spoilers from all the Marvel movies so
far because we'll be talking about all
the Easter eggs and connections between
this Avengers end game and the upcoming
Marvel phase 4 movies all number of
these as we go along just to keep things
organized so starting at the beginning
of the movie we start from the
perspective of the villain Ivan Vanko
aka whiplash in Russia watching the
ending scene of the first Iron Man movie
alive as it's happening we get our back
story on how whiplashes father was a
one-time colleague of iron man's father
Howard Stark helping him create the now
famous arc reactor technology but being
branded a thief and a spy exile to
disgrace back to Russia as a criminal
the movie is all about legacy so they
start with whiplash and his father all I
can give you is my knowledge so
obviously that theme would be continued
between Howard Stark and his son Tony
Stark then between Iron Man and
spider-man in the MCU up to Spider Man
far from home when Spiderman would have
to defend Tony's legacy from usurpers
like Mysterio the next Tony Stark I
trust you say edith whiplashes father
dies he vows to avenge remember that
word avenge his father's death tearing
down everything that Iron Man is using
his own arc reactor technology the big
montage of him creating his new weapons
is meant to be a shot-for-shot copy of
the original montage of Iron Man in the
cave creating his Mark 1 suit the theme
continues through the movie because
whiplash starts out with that beta
version of his armor like Iron Man's
mark 1 then by the end of the movie he's
upgraded his armor to something more
akin to the traditional Crimson Dynamo
suit from the comics like Iron Man
upgrading from his mark 4 to mark 5 and
then mark 6 whiplash in this movie
played by Mickey Rourke is a bit of a
combination of a couple characters
Crimson Dynamo in the comic book
whiplash were actually going back to
Russia in the black
movie but that's it during the 90s
hopefully we'll see more Easter eggs and
references to other Russian Marvel
characters it's implied that whiplash
dies at the end of this movie so I don't
expect Mickey Rourke's character to come
back but they might reference Crimson
Dynamo or whiplash during the Black
Widow movie there's a bunch of newspaper
clippings and references to earlier MCU
events here there's an article about
Iron Man's stabilizing relations between
the US and Russia written by Rob down
aka Robert Downey jr. they have their
big intro scene with the ACDC shoot to
thrill call back to the first Iron Man
movie ac/dc kind of became his theme
music in the MCU there was a real big
deleted scene of him opening the movie
like this it had him booting in the
toilet while he was wearing his mark for
armor then jumps out after Pepper Potts
kisses the helmet and throws it at the
back of the plane you may remember part
of that scene from the original trailer
the reason why they got rid of it is
because during that version they hyped
up way more of his alcoholism and
drinking problems as part of the demon
in a bottle adaptation of the movie I
think that Marvel just didn't want to
get that dark with it and they already
had the Palladium poisoning storyline
and used that as their demon and a
bottle of style story the source of Iron
Man's strength his legacy was literally
poisoning him to death when he lands in
the armor comes off he says it's good to
be back
referencing the sequel celebrating the
success of the first movie the critical
and financial success he brings back his
father's stark Expo in Queens New York
which we later see them referenced
during the flashbacks at the beginning
of spider-man homecoming in Peters short
film set prior to the events of the
airport battle in Captain America Civil
War there's a lot of Spider Man Easter
eggs during the movie as spider-man
lives in Queens or lived in Queens when
the stark Expo was happening and he was
around for all this we get the intro
scene featuring John Slattery as older
Howard Stark for the first time this is
meant to be a big Walt Disney Easter Egg
for the broadcast that he would do
talking about Epcot Center and
Disneyland introducing new programs when
they got to the Captain America movie
and we went even further back in the
timeline we saw the original version of
the stark Expo back during the 1940s
with a younger Dominic Cooper version of
Howard Stark there's a lot of Howard
Stark Walt Disney Ironman references
during this movie this was around the
time that Disney bought Marvel and
brought them into the
so that's why you started to see so many
Disney Easter eggs in these movies I'm
also kind of hoping in real life because
they just officially canceled Comic Con
this summer Kevin Feige we'll just do a
full-blown Walt Disney broadcast like
this revealing all these Marvel phase
for details and trailers and drop it
this summer one of the other really big
Walt Disney Easter eggs is at the end of
the film they actually play his carousel
a progress theme song they said at the
movie version of his demon in a bottle
story lion when he starts looking at his
poison levels while standing in front of
the Howard Stark clips which would later
provide him with a solution to his
problem in that new element this is a
string of celebrity cameos starting with
Olivia Munn who got her start as a host
on g4 she's playing chess roberts a
reporter for WHIH that news station
that shows up all over the Marvel films
you all probably recognize Larry Ellison
he just playing himself during the movie
Stan Lee his cameo scene is him as Larry
King Seth Green and his wife show up in
the back of an elevator we get a big
Fantastic Four crossover moment
Fantastic Four actress kate mara cameos
as a court worker giving him his summons
to appear before the Senate committee
which itself is another Howard Hughes
reference Stan Lee said the real-life
Howard Hughes was the inspiration for
the original comic book Iron Man when he
created him but Iron Man 2 makes that
reference more literal when he has to
testify in front of Congress defending
his business practices just like real
life Howard Hughes did back in the day
and we all talk about Spider Man cameo
scenes the little kid in the Iron Man
mask shows up at the beginning here to
Iron Man Pat's him on the head it's the
same little kid and the Iron Man mask
that he saves later in the movie
famously Tom Holland when they were
promoting spider-man homecoming said
that this was Peter Parker Kevin Feige
later confirmed the easter egg as
official MCU canon so we'll call this -
spider-man cameo scenes during Iron Man
2 in the movie though the actor
underneath this mask was Jon Favreau's
son from real life when he faces the
Senate committee the committee is led by
Garry Shandling senator Stern who would
later reappear and be revealed as an
agent of Hydra in Winter Soldier we meet
our Iron Man comic book villain Justin
Hammer who's something of another
Salieri to Iron Man's Mozart in the
movie just like Obadiah Stane from the
first Iron Man movie right now Justin
Hammer is still currently
live in the MCU being held at cj prison
he later guest-starred in Iron Man 3
one-shot movie all hail the king and
they referenced his hammer tech during
the Marvel Netflix Luke Cage series they
could totally bring back Justin Hammer
or hammer tech as part of a Thunderbolts
Disney Plus series when Justin Hammer is
trying to give Tony the business in
front of the Senate committee he
references shield and sword - really big
Marvel phase four Easter eggs we
recently learned that the spider-man far
from home post credits scene with Nick
Fury on that space station is actually
this sword space station from the comics
sword is a comic book team that will
debut on the Wandavision Disney Plus
series the difference between sword and
shield is that sword is mostly based in
outer space on this space station
they're responsible for defending Earth
from threats from outer space shield is
mostly concerned with threats based on
planet Earth when Justin Hammer says
shield in this scene it's also a
reference to the Nick Fury storyline
during this movie becoming a much bigger
character after the original Iron Man
post-credit scene we meet Don Cheadle
Rhodey for the first time they have a
big wink reference when he walks in I'm
here let's deal with it move on they
famously recast Rhodey after Terrence
Howard from the first movie got into a
big pay dispute with Marvel when Iron
Man is busy not paying attention to the
committee you'd notice there's an
Illuminati Easter Egg on his phone
that's another big Marvel phase for
Marvel phase 5 Easter Egg now that they
have all the x-men and Fantastic Four
characters they can actually do a legit
Illuminati MCU team so this is just
Kevin Feige really early on teasing
eventual big crossover the way that he
did in that deleted Ironman post-credits
scene which reference x-men and
spider-man crossover we go back to venko
we get another ten rings Easter Egg when
he gets some information from them the
ten rings or the mandarins group from
the MCU heavily featured in the Iron Man
movies but the name is also a reference
to the 10 alien rings of power that the
Mandarin wears the fake Mandarin would
later debut during Iron Man 3 after this
but we're going to meet the real
Mandarin of the MCU during shang-chi in
the legend of the ten rings where we'll
also see the actual physical ten rings
of power from the comics this actor is
Tony Leung he's the person that they
cast to play the real-life Mandarin of
the MCU the movie will be a little bit
like Marvel's version of Bruce Lee's
Enter the Dragon
you notice that the alias that whiplash
is using is Boris Turgenev it's the name
of the second version of Crimson Dynamo
from the comics who takes the mantle
from Ivan Vanko so maybe we'll see a
second version the Crimson Dynamo in the
MCU in the future we go back to Iron Man
in the boxing scene referencing happy
Hogan's history in the comics as a boxer
and we meet Scarlett Johansson's Black
Widow for the first time Scarlett
Johansson famously was not Marvel's
first pick for Black Widow either
originally they wanted Emily Blunt who
around this time was getting ready to
get married to John Krasinski in real
life who marvel was also after at the
same time for the Captain America role
before they went to Chris Evans right
now everyone's talking about Marvel
phase 4 John Krasinski doing a new
version of Fantastic Four is Reed
Richards and possibly Emily Blunt
becoming the new Invisible Woman
marvel's been after them for a long time
to be in marvel movies so it's just
funny to see things come back around
full circle the reason that Emily Blunt
had to pass on Black Widow is because of
a scheduling conflict with another movie
she was doing paving the way for scar
Joe who will later see this year in
Black Widow the name that she's using
during this movie Natalie rushman is
based on her comic book alias Nancy
rushman from the spider-man comics we
has some more celebrity cameos when go
back to the race in Monaco Elon Musk
cameos as himself the MCU present-day
version of Iron Man is based a little
bit on Elon Musk later in the movie when
Justin Hammer breaks venko at her prison
to come work for him in that big
warehouse that's actually Elon Musk's
SpaceX warehouse in real life where they
build their rockets while they're at the
reception here they take a picture of
Tony and pepper which later shows up
during the first Avengers movie at the
bar when Iron Man is confronting Loki I
have an army we have a Hulk he goes down
to race the car we get another rocks an
Easter egg just as Vanko comes out
revealing himself as whiplash and we get
our Iron Man mark 5 briefcase suit for
the first time this sort of wink at the
fact that this is way more mobile than
his other armors which up to this point
he's had to have a bunch of machines to
put on and take off the whole idea with
each new armors that they get more
advanced more mobile more powerful until
we get to Avengers infinity war in
Avengers end game with the Nano armors
after which he no longer needs the
mobile armory his new nano
armours can literally become any weapon
or any piece of armour that he needs
them to be on the fly when they flash a
news broadcast showing Vanko being
arrested they used a picture of
real-life Mickey Rourke being arrested
on drug charges from a long time ago
then we get that big party scene with
Iron Man in the armor getting super
drunk as part of the demon in a bottle
storyline the DJ behind him is real-life
DJ Adam Goldstein rody comes they fight
he takes the Iron Man mark to prototype
armor they later repurposed that as the
war machine mark 1 during their fight
Robert Downey jr. even says the name war
machine they pay off a really big Iron
Man 1 whiplash reference when this
character comes back from the first
movie during that he used the callsign
whiplash for one of the pilots chasing
down Iron Man we get that very famous
Randy's donut scene that they put in all
the promos with a severely hungover
Iron Man eating Donuts sitting inside
the giant donut this is an actual
restaurant that you can go to in Los
Angeles when the lockdown because of the
virus is over of course Nick Fury gives
Iron Man the business and they reveal
black widows secret identity he drops a
big thor easter egg talking about
something happening in the southwest
that they later pay off in the
post-credits scene Coulson later
references it when he says he has to go
to New Mexico and it shows up on Nick
Fury's map at the end of the movie there
are a ton of e strays on all these maps
so I'll cover that at the end of the
video too we get an Avengers age of
Ultron Easter Egg when Vanko is talking
to hammer saying that drones are better
people make problems
Tony's iron Legion would famously or
infamously serve as the origin of Ultron
in combination with the mine stone in
another big Spiderman Easter Egg he
later references that in spider-man
homecoming when he gave spider-man the
business about the suit not making the
man it's not about the tech it's about
the man inside the suit they put Tony
under house arrest effectively which is
kind of what's happening to all of us in
real life now because of the virus he
gets a big trunk of his father's
belongings there are a ton of Easter
eggs in here he's wearing Howard Starks
old bathrobe there's a Captain America
number one comic book in the trunk here
another teaser for the upcoming Captain
America movie as Howard Stark was a huge
part of the super soldier program
Ironman starts hearing his father talk
about legacy you're the greatest thing I
created some
these things good somebody's bad about
his history with vanko's father their
original work together developing the
arc reactor he finds his father's
tesseract diary with research trying to
use it to create a new source of clean
energy later we would see Dominic
Cooper's Howard start grabbing that off
the ocean floor at the end of the first
Captain America movie Howard Stark
studied the tesseract for years until
the early 90s when he and shield created
project Pegasus hiring Marvel who would
secretly be revealed as a Kree scientist
giving her the tesseract to study for a
way to create faster than light travel
you have to remember that in the MCU
ships don't travel past Lightspeed like
they do in Star Wars they use jump gates
to get around the universe which we
would later see them pay off during
guardians of the galaxy 2 in that funny
montage all the names on all these
blueprints in the film reels are just
names of the crew members who worked on
Iron Man 2 in real life and then Iron
Man obviously here's his father talking
about legacy connects the dots on the
stark Expo model learning that hides the
secret work that he did trying to create
a new element based on tesseract
research which Ironman then completes so
the big thing here is that Iron Man is
basing his new arc reactor technology to
power it based on infinity stone
technology which explains in the MCU why
he can be so powerful he's using an
infinity stone to power himself
effectively during this montage of him
creating the element there's a deleted
scene where he references projects
Pegasus Exodus and Goliath years before
they would pay those things off big
Marvel phase 4 Easter eggs to project
Pegasus like I said was featured during
the Captain Marvel movie it's also the
name of the base that they had at the
first Avengers movie that blew up where
they were studying the tesseract if it
wasn't clear that was the same base that
they featured in the flashbacks during
the Captain Marvel movie project Goliath
was featured during ant-man in the wasp
when we met the real-life Goliath comic
book character said that he worked with
Hank Pym on a project called quote
unquote Goliath then project Exodus is a
big Eternals
x-men Easter egg that they'll pay off in
Marvel phase 4 during the Eternals movie
biblical Exodus in the way that the
Eternals left society in the creation of
MCU mutants more Captain America Easter
eggs because we're getting ready for
them
movie Coulson gets super pissed off at
Iron Man when he shows very little
respect for Captain America's prototype
shield Coulson would later be revealed
as a hilariously massive Captain America
stand in the first Avengers movie I
watched you while you were sleeping we
got our big final boss fight hammers
drones go off the rails Black Widow
attacks with happy Hogan this footage of
her fight scene would later be seen in
the black widow trailer recently showing
taskmaster studying her moves and at the
end of the movie Iron Man learns about
the Avengers initiative document that we
would later see Nick Fury drafting in
the Captain Marvel movie all across
these screens are a billion different
Easter eggs
there's whi H footage from Incredible
Hulk we just saw in that movie on the
map over here from left to right there's
LA for Iron Man's mansion in the events
of the Iron Man movies there's New
Mexico for Thor's hammer there's a point
of interest in New York for Incredible
Hulk in the stark Expo fight there's one
in the polar icecaps for Captain America
where he was found there's one in Norway
for the town where the tesseract was
found at the beginning of the Captain
America movie there's one over here in
Africa for Wakanda which we would see in
the black panther movie and then one in
the Atlantic Ocean off the coast of
Africa which is another big Marvel phase
for Easter Egg for Atlantis which they
referenced during Avengers endgame then
we get our big post-credit scene where
Coulson arrives in New Mexico to find
Thor's hammer which has just landed on
earth everyone let me know in the
comments if you spotted any big Marvel
phase 4 Easter eggs during Iron Man 2
that I didn't mention during the video
because I'm doing these in release order
my next Marvel infinity saga video will
be for the first Thor movie that should
post in the next couple of days
everyone click here for all my infinity
Saga re-watch Easter Egg videos starting
with the first Iron Man movie and
everyone click here for that brand new
John Krasinski Marvel phase 4 teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!